-I'm so happy to have you here.
-Thank you.
-"Prime Time."
"Prime Time," Deion Sanders.
You don't like --
You don't like "Neon" Deion?
-No.
-You don't like "Neon" Deion?
-No! They tried to give me that
at Florida State.
I'd already earned
"Prime Time" in high school.
I dropped like 37 that night,
had two dunks back to back,
curl was wet, looked dry.
[ Laughter ]
And we were on our way home
on the bus, and my homie says,
"You know what, man?
You're prime time."
I said, "You right."
So, it was birthed then.
You can't give me no nickname.
I'm from the inner city.
You can't just
give us a nickname.
You got to earn that thing,
and I earned it -- "Prime Time."
-"Neon" Deion, though.
-I don't like "Neon" Deion.
I don't like that.
-Yeah.
Well, what do I call you now?
Do I call you "Prime" or Coach?
-You can call me anything.
You call me "Coach Prime."
-"Coach Prime."
-Yeah, like --
-Yeah, I'm gonna call you
"Coach Prime."
It's back with new episodes.
Congratulations on that.
-Thank you.
-Pretty historic season,
by the way.
-Yeah.
-It's the first time
in Jackson State history,
I want to say, that the team
won 11 games in a season.
-Yes.
-Also want to -- yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's -- that's you.
And two of your sons
play on the team.
-Yes.
-Do they get any
special treatment?
-None whatsoever.
First of all,
they may get it harder
than the other kids.
If you know which kids
are my son,
other than the way they look,
I'm not doing my job coaching.
I'm tough.
I'm disciplined.
I'm tenacious on the kids.
But I want them to be smart,
tough, fast, disciplined,
with character.
And I gotta have that.
If I don't have it,
you're not playing for us.
I demand that.
-Yeah, you do.
That's good. That's why --
That's why you win.
I love this.
I love the show.
But do the kid know that
not only did you
play the Super Bowl, you also
played in the World Series?
-The kids that play for me?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, they kind of --
Trust me,
when we travel somewhere,
there's police escorts.
It's --
We do it big, so they kind of
know who their coach is.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-They gotta know they coach
is a little different.
He's cut a little different.
-Do they know that
their coach also had, like,
a brief rap career?
-They know they coach had hits.
Yeah, hits.
[ Laughter ]
-Hitss.
-Hits-suh.
-Yeah, you add an extra S --
the hitss, yeah, yeah.
-Hits-suh.
-I bought this CD.
-You should've.
-I did.
[ Laughter ]
-You should've.
-This is
"Prime Time Deion Sanders."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Look at you, man.
Come on.
-[ Laughing ]
"Must be the Money" was my jam.
-"Must be the Money"
was the one.
-That was the jam right there.
Actually, we have a little bit
of the music video.
-Uh-oh.
-Just to remind you.
-Oh, Lord.
-Yeah. Take a look.
♪ Flashing lights
on the dance floor ♪
♪ The DJ says my name
as I make my intro ♪
♪ Must be the money ♪
-♪ Must be the money ♪
-♪ I got so much jewels ♪
♪ Must be the money ♪
-♪ Must be the money ♪
-Yeah, that is "Prime Time"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's my man.
-I thank God.
God allowed me
to live out all my dreams.
And you got to understand,
every athlete wants to be
an entertainer,
and every entertainer
wants to be somewhat
of an athlete.
-Exactly.
-And I got to live out my dream.
I'm -- I was excited.
I still have hits
in me left, though.
-You -- You have more hitss.
-Yes-suh.
-Yeah, exactly, hits-suh.
[ Laughter ]
Your just finished
your full season
at Jackson State,
which is a HBCU.
-Yes.
-What made you
take that coaching job?
-Why not?
Why not?
It was a tremendous opportunity
to advance equality,
to allow people
to understand there is a --
not just a devastation,
that it's a turbulent time
in HBCU sports.
And I just wanted to bring a --
shed light, bring equality,
bring a spotlight
on the programs.
And that's what we've
accomplished at Jackson State.
-Yeah, you've done that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's amazing.
You're also having
the NFL look at players?
-Yeah, well,
we already had an NFL combine.
We have the NFL pro day
on our campus,
which is going
to now track NFL scouts.
They've come from the --
Dozens of scouts has come
to our practices now.
All of the HBCUs, we're getting
better quality of players.
Now, kids coming out
of high school,
they're not saying no, and the
HBCUs are recruiting them now.
Once upon a time, they didn't
think they could get them.
But now they're saying,
"You know what?
We're going after
that four-star,
we're going after
that five-star."
We just happened to get
the best kid in the country,
the number-one recruit,
period, last season.
[ Applause ]
-Period.
-Yeah.
-Our buddy -- our buddy Shaq --
we love him.
He was talking about you
the other day.
And he said that he thinks
that you should maybe be
the coach of the Dallas Cowboys.
-I love Jerry Jones,
I love the Cowboys,
but I cannot coach pros.
I have a problem
with a professional athlete
not doing his job
and he's getting
handsomely paid.
I don't have
any toleration for that.
There's some out there
working their butts off,
but there's plenty out there
that just don't get it.
And I would fight.
I would fight every day,
as a coach.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I couldn't do it.
I'm old school.
-You're old school, yeah.
-I'm old school, man.
You know, we -- you made it
this far from your work ethic.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it -- it would be tough.
-Yeah, because you see
these kids, they -- they want --
they want to play.
They want to play the game.
-Yes. The college kids,
they want to play.
-Exactly.
-Yes.
-That's right.
There's also --
What do you think about the --
the thing that's been coming up
that there's not enough
Black coaches in the NFL?
-That's true.
-Yeah.
-But the solvency of the problem
is where everyone is deferred.
You can't make a billionaire do
what a billionaire
don't want to do.
You can't make --
you hire a housekeeper
you don't want to hire.
To solve -- bring solvency
to this problem,
I think we should demand
that there are three to four
expansion teams,
and you give those teams
to an ethnic group.
Then you see how it --
see how it falls.
See how it plays out, as owners.
We need three Black owners,
and let's see how it plays out.
[ Applause ]
-I like that.
-I like it, too.
-Let's talk about "Coach Prime."
This follows the ups and downs
of the season.
Can you talk about what people
are gonna see this season?
-It's gonna be phenomenal.
Dana Beers is a producer.
"Dana Beers is a producer" --
that sounded funny
coming out my mouth.
"Dana Beers is a producer."
He's phenomenal.
You're gonna see trials,
tribulations,
especially with myself
personally.
You're gonna see
these kids triumph.
You're gonna see devastation,
tribulations, and trials,
and situations that they
overcome adversity.
But you're gonna see a real
inside look of how we get down.
And we don't sugarcoat anything.
-You don't.
-No, you're gonna see the truth.
-Yeah.
Do you remember those moments?
I mean, I know
what happened to you,
but also, I mean,
those moments where you go,
like, "I can't do it"?
-I never said I can't do it.
That's not in my vocabulary,
"I can't do it."
-Never?
-No, I'm the
Little Engine That Could.
I was on that train.
[ Laughter ]
I said, "I think I can,
I think I can."
-Yeah.
-"I think I can."
-"I think I can.
I know I can."
-"I know I can."
There you go.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a peek at this season
of "Coach Prime."
Take a look.
-I'm tired of us just not living
up to our fullest potential.
Fellas, I'm tired.
And it's making me weary.
I didn't lose my voice
from yelling.
I lose my voice because it's
a tactic of the enemy
to try to mess with my mobility
and my voice,
because my voice changes things.
And I'm tired.
I'm gonna continue to fight,
though, in my weariness.
I'm gonna continue to believe,
even though nobody else
believes.
I'm gonna continue to walk even
if I have to shoot myself up.
But each and every one of y'all
give me strength, man.
Y'all give me purpose.
Y'all keep me going.
Y'all give me hope.
Y'all make me believe.
And y'all could do that today.
Because I'm not gonna
lie to you -- I'm tired.
If you don't do
nothing else today,
give me some strength,
because I'm tired.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, right when I end,
I look away, and I say,
"Now give me my theme music,"
and that's when it comes on,
and the kids go crazy, man.
-You know how to do it.
-They love it.
-That's Deion Sanders,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Coach Prime"
on all Barstool Sports
digital channels.